je préfère la tranquillité au tunnel de
la grande ville alors veux-tu on arrête
de parler un petit peu mais on profite
du soleil la pièce intimiste Courville
jouait en français à Taïwan avec
sous-titres en mandarin a été resserré
depuis sa première à Québec à l'automne
2021 raccourci de près d'une heure
1975 c'était aussi
l'été 2016 son propos sur l'adolescence
et le climat social au Québec dans les
années 70 trouvés
le monde était divisé en deux entre le
bloc communiste et le les pays
capitalistes puis bon maintenant avec ce
qui se passe avec la Russie avec la
tension du nucléaire qui revient c'est
sûr que beaucoup les spectacles
reviennent à la mode les spectacles sont
à propos tout à coup on pense qu'on est
nostalgique dans ces spectacles qu'on
parle du passé mais
le passé retentit toujours sous d'autres
formes
[Musique]
la pièce résonne d'autant plus à Taïwan
dans le climat actuel avec la menace
d'évasion par la Chine beaucoup plus
tendue et beaucoup plus complexe moi je
la comprends pas bien ceci dit j'essaie
de la comprendre parfois que je
comprends pas bien alors oui c'est sûr
qu'on sent que c'est une préoccupation
et comme je dis cherche il cherche à
être compris par les amis quand on sent
qu'il y a des bateaux chinois qui de
plus en plus enfin c'est peut-être un
peu comme les tank quand j'étais en
Russie c'est peut-être imminent mais en
même temps c'est peut-être mais c'est ça
donc ça veut dire que ça devienne ça
s'incarne cette idée-là qu'on a toujours
pensé qui est une menace comme ça qui
est plus une menace
moins tangible mais là on sent que c'est
on sent que c'est présent
[Musique]
la complicité de Robert Lepage avec le
public taïwanais habitué au spectacle
multidisciplinaire asiatique ne date pas
d'hier il en a fait une on a honte en
Asie pour se tourner une société très
très moderne très ouverte
et le public est très jeune et ça c'est
si on veut quand on joue en Asie par
exemple dans le code de Courville où on
utilise des marionnettes on n'a pas
expliqué au public que c'est pas un
spectacle pour enfants qu'on fait c'est
ce qu'il faut faire
de façon générale Amérique du Nord faut
encore expliquer au public ben oui il y
a des marionnettes mais c'est pas
nécessairement passe partout la pièce
Courville malgré son côté sombre se
termine avec un renouveau une note
d'espoir que Robert Lepage tient à
partager dans le contexte mondial actuel
il faut que les artistes aussi soient
pas je critique de leur époque qui soit
pas juste des témoin de l'époque je
pense qu'il faut aussi ok de l'espoir
faut qu'on participe à la conversation
comment on se sort d'une situation comme
ça comment on se tourne vers l'autre
comment comprendre l'autre Robert Lepage
reviendra d'ailleurs à la fin du mois
sur les racines de l'identité québécoise
avec la première du projet Riopel à
Montréal qui est un espèce de grande
fresque sur lequel il faut encore
travailler un peu mais blanc
Radio-Canada